- My top three favorite
movies of all time,
this is very easy for me.
- Oof, top three phobias.
- Okay.
(Kelly gasps)
- I love this one.
Top three favorite animals
that I wish I could have as a pet?
Oh, my God.
(upbeat music)
All right, y'all!
Kelly Clarkson Show is back.
And to officially celebrate season three,
we are gonna play My Top Three.
I rhymed. Didn't mean to do that.
Ooh, my top three movies I
could watch again and again,
that would be, definitely,
It's Complicated,
definitely, Goonies.
Man, I watch a lot of movies
that are like I really, really love,
oh, Pride and Prejudice.
Sorry. Love that one.
Top three superheroes?
Ugh, okay.
Well, obviously, Superman,
Iron Man,
Aquaman.
(romantic music)
Come on. He's so good
looking and cute and sweet.
I love him.
My top three phobias?
I guess, I don't like odd numbers.
That's weird, right?
Like, but I'm OCD about it.
Like if I'm in your car and like,
it's on like 23, I can't take it.
So, it has to be either 22 or 24.
And that's just a thing,
like a numbers thing with me.
I don't know why, it's been
like that since I was a kid.
You know, don't like liars.
(Kelly laughing)
I guess that's like, it's not.
I don't really have like a lot of phobias,
I don't think. I only did top two.
Notice what I did there?
(Kelly laughing)
Top three favorite dance moves?
Well, obviously the body roll,
like kinda like the snake, kinda the same.
Well, no, the snake is different.
I like the body roll and the snake.
Lil Paula Abdul throwback.
But I do, I do really
love the lawnmower, guys.
It's a great solid move.
And it's either you're pushing
or you're sitting on one.
It's two different moves in one.
Top three things on my bucket list?
I wanna build a big, giant lodge and like,
I wanna die there.
I wanna retire there.
(Kelly laughing)
I don't know the location yet, but I.
I wanna take my kids on an African safari
'cause I've done it a lot
in my life and I love it,
and I think they'd adore it,
but I have to wait till they're older.
So, that's on the bucket
list for me and my family.
I don't know.
I'm starting to like, have like
more off time in the summer.
I feel like a teacher's schedule.
So, I really wanna like
travel more in the summer.
I want like, you know,
the global pandemic thing to be like done
and we get to travel again.
So that's, I like traveling with my kids
and showing them like all over the world.
I would love that, so I
like doing that for them.
(Kelly gasping)
I love this one!
Top three favorite animals
that I wish I could have as a pet?
Oh, my God.
I'm obsessed with wolves.
I love wolves.
I love that they travel in packs
'cause I'm that person
like anything I'm doing,
I can have fun as long as like,
people I love are doing with me.
We're in a pack.
And then I also,
I really do love big, giant grizzly bears.
I think they're really cool and fearsome,
but really cool as well.
But I will say,
another favorite I've been
obsessed with since I was a kid
is a white tiger.
Because I think that they're-
wait, can I change mine?
'Cause wait, I love bears.
But well, I love,
I love cheetahs as well, so,
I kinda have a top four.
But I will say white tiger,
cheetah, bear and wolf.
I'm picking four.
I change rules.
(Kelly laughing)
Top three favorite things
about having my own talk show?
Definitely like, I get to meet people
like Julie Andrews and Chris Martin,
like all these amazing people on my show,
like people that I've
loved since I was a kid,
and it completely inspired me
to be where I'm at right now.
I think that's the coolest part
is I get to meet people
I really am inspired by.
The really cool part as well,
probably the coolest part,
is that we really get to shine a light
on a lot of like unsung
hero kind of situations.
So, there's a lot of good
happening in the world.
I like that we get to shine a
spotlight on people like that.
The third part is super
selfish and self indulgent,
but I like that me and my band
still get to play music
regularly, like every day.
So, even if we're doing like covers,
it's like really fun.
So, you know, I've toured
over the last 20 years,
like doing my music.
So, it's nice to like do
other people's music every day
and we get to have fun with that.
So, probably singing, I
still get to sing and stuff.
So, hope you like it,
if you don't, oh, well.
(Kelly giggling)
So, I've also asked this season
a lot of celebrity guests
to give me their top three
of like, favorite things.
So, we'll see what happens.
(upbeat music)
All right, so what are
your top three musicals?
- A Chorus Line, Pal Joey, and Cabaret.
- Gypsy,
Hello Dolly!
West Side Story.
- The three musicals
that I can watch over
and over and over again
are The Sound of Music,
West Side Story, and Cabaret.
The three best!
- Hairspray with Nikki Blonsky,
Chicago with Renée Zellweger,
and Rent.
- [Kelly] Okay, so your top three movies
you could watch again and again and again.
- My top three favorite
movies of all time,
this is very easy for me,
are First Wives Club,
To Wong Foo, Thanks for
Everything! Julie Newmar,
and Best in Show.
- Top three movies I could
watch over and over again,
oh, Happy Together,
Bridesmaids,
and The Incredibles?
Leave that in there.
I want people to know that I'm
trying to communicate range.
- Foul Play.
My son just made a movie
at movie making camp.
I could watch that over and over.
And Terms of Endearment.
- My favorite movies are
Coming to America One
and Coming to America Two.
- And my favorite movie
is A Raisin in the Sun
starring Sidney Poitier.
- Oh my god. You know what?
I'm gonna go with the three
that no matter what point
they are on television,
I watch them.
A Few Good Men, Gladiator, Top Gun.
- Ooh, I was just talking about this.
Labyrinth, Three Amigos!
and Desperately Seeking Susan.
- [Kelly] What are your top
three flavors of ice cream?
- My top three ice cream flavors are
like banana nut caramel,
birthday cake,
and strawberry.
- For some reason I love
pistachio nut, love pistachio nut.
Pecan praline because my brother
kinda turned me on today.
And for some reason, I don't drink at all,
but I like Häagen-Dazs'
rum raisin ice cream,
so go figure.
Maybe I wanna get tipsy.
- Oh, okay. Simple, simple for you.
- Yeah. Cookies and cream.
- Cookies and cream.
- The Irish,
no, no.
- Cookies and cream.
- No, but I love the Irish.
- Spirit?
- You know? It's like a-
- You think there's liquor in there?
- Yeah.
- I see.
- You mean there isn't?
- What's the third?
- Vanilla with chocolate syrup.
Like a sundae.
- Oh, okay, right.
- With a banana.
- Swiss almond vanilla,
coffee, cherry garcia.
- Cherry Garcia.
- [Kelly] All right, your top
three phobias slash fears.
- Someone else filming me
when I don't have control
over the lighting,
jellyfish,
and dresses that you can't wear bras with.
- Oof, top three phobias.
- Okay, I would say, number one,
oh, you, you look like
you have it, you go.
- Coulrophobia, fear of clowns.
- That is, yeah, clowns are creepy.
Wait, what, what makes it our favorite?
Is it that we really like it
or we really don't like it.
I would say that mine is miso-
was it misophonia?
- Oh, the food sounds.
- Yeah, I can't stand food noises like
(chewing noise)
Just shut your mouth.
- Oh also,
the fear of people who look like you.
(man screaming)
Oh, gosh.
- Man, looking good.
- Top three phobias.
Trypophobia, little
holes next to each other.
Arachnophobia. I'm stupid like that.
And whatever falling into a sinkhole.
These are all like hole
based and there's a spider.
There's a spider phobia too,
but falling into a hole.
Oh no, getting hit by a bike.
Getting hit by a bike phobia.
- Okay, top three phobias.
Spiders, number one,
like huge major spiders.
Number two, dishonest people
really scare the hmm out of me.
Number three, doing top
three lists on social media.
(Connie chuckling)